[Music]
[Music]
i just hope we have another one of those
another one of the supreme court
victories so that aoc can get fake
arrested
[Applause]
how many of us were just hoping that
that fake arrest turned into a real
arrest
i don't need a handcuffs like all right
sweetheart watch your head as you go
into the paddy wagon oh no i'm sorry
[Applause]
now your other eye's googly
[Applause]
how will we know who you're screeching
at
i'm sorry let's try this again
oh no i'm sorry it shipped the mule
tooth ah
i'm sure they can fix it up at the feed
store
tractor supply or something
phoenix houston
charleston nashville new york
baltimore
the rebels with a cause comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com tour
i'm just not ready to have to take care
of another human being it's not your
fault it's the man's it's not my
responsibility a baby is not the
mother's responsibility baby i just want
to make sure that i'm making the right
decision you know because i'm so young
and i've got my whole life ahead of me
and
i wasn't trying to do this and it's
stupid
yeah but it's not your fault that you
let a man in you so
i should go back to being selfish yes be
a selfish woman
get rid of your baby kind of
not
cute yeah you got an ugly pre-made
bearded baby
it doesn't cry i think it has asperger's
that's going to be even more expensive
special schools
you got to get rid of it just throw it
into stupid baby river
all right
you're right
yeah there you go he doesn't even cry i
think he has asperger's
kick it
just kill come on go pick the baby
kick the baby baby
see puppy it's having a great time going
down the river he's not even scared
right this was the right choice i know
what was the right choice i wouldn't
steer you wrong
if he seems wrong he's dead
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
one man's trash
got a new slave everybody oh got a new
slave you ever catch a slave this big
frank no you didn't
new slave
right here oh well oh
wow let's get out of here
why don't you cry
you have aspergers
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
you noticed that was a hollow sip until
because i didn't know how hot it was
going to be the answer is too hot you're
faking it everything's going to stop it
this is a family show now
we uh have a lot to get to today my
fever broke last night completely so i'm
good uh slept well you know what's funny
two things can be true i had one coveted
positive one coveted negative and
another coped positive i would gladly
take this over any kind of a cold or flu
that i've had it's just the fever and
the fatigue let me know you know what
comment below before we get to anything
if you've had covert recently this is
the second time that i've that i've had
it and they've both been very mild but
uh i also know it's not pleasant
sometimes people like oh you don't want
to wear a mess did you get covered did
you like it
no no i'm not saying that it's fun
i'm just saying that you don't shut down
the economy and ruin our country for an
entire generation because of it it's
still unpleasant two things can be true
as a matter of fact you would almost
assume those things to be true all right
today we have a lot to talk about uh
demi lovato
girl again but more importantly kansas
speaking of girls uh and lesbians who
for some reason have an incredibly
vested interest in abortion kansas just
had a vote on abortion they're still
going to allow abortion spoiler alert up
until 22 weeks oh
five and a half months the horror
this is just like pre-suffragette uh and
then uh we'll also talk about something
that uh you know it's kind of near and
dear to my heart the senate uh burn pit
bill you know people been talking about
that's how it's kind of been coined for
for veterans
it's been misrepresented of course and
it's been used as political football all
because jon stewart decided to show up
and insult some people so we're talking
about that today and also hopefully kind
of walking you through a logical
exercise and when something doesn't pass
a sniff test like the burn pit bill yeah
why hopefully you'll learn how to ask
some questions and find the answers and
we'll make all of our references uh
available gerald a is with me you good
sir i'm doing well how are you i'm doing
f i'm doing fine now i didn't sleep but
the fever broke and now now i'm good so
hopefully i'll be fine tomorrow and you
know him you love him i'll be on tour
with them live with credit.com tour
phoenix arizona september 16th at the
arizona financial theater houston on
september 17th these are the uh the
first ones here only a little more than
a month away so get your tickets and
then charleston west virginia that's
like a a an arena october 8th at the
charleston coliseum live with card.com
dave landau how are you ahoy good about
you sir i'm doing better you were sick
too but you had like a sinus infection
that's what i have i'm an antibiotic so
i'm feeling a little bit better today
well what you have to do is take those
uh those there's a little inside uh
inside tip probiotics that's what i hear
yeah but i don't wait what i had someone
tell me to take probiotics because you
know antibiotics sorry if you have
children antibiotic induced diarrhea
and so i went to the pharmacist i said
you know they told me to get some
probiotics this is the right one
and it was the closest i ever came to
crapping my pants as an adult i went
home and i checked it it was 80 billion
cfus of pro regularity oh that's
probiotics oh just make a nice metamucil
shake
you're good so my question before we
move on have uh
rigorous abortion laws you think if they
turned conservatives against each other
republicans against each other a lot of
people are saying this is a losing issue
i don't see it as we'll talk about
kansas but before we do any of that
we always love going to our favorite
state and by that i mean the worst state
uh it's time for uh new york empire
state of crime watch
[Music]
hey did we change dave's monitor because
i can't see his lovely face we uh had to
lower the mic because i we couldn't see
my face on the screen oh okay uh but
yeah we did change it all right well now
i can't see the wonderful pedophile
stash hey oh no
it's a compliment
it's the highest compliment one can give
a stash it's true that's true that's
okay you don't need to change it there
casey it's fine it's fine i can see the
top of his head he can look like wilson
that's right billy avoid homosexuals yes
that's how you avoid monkey pop yes
follow these simple steps number one
don't engage in sodomy with strange men
number two congratulations
you've avoided monkey box yeah good job
all right
speaking of uh monkey pox we're here in
new york uh
they need more vex yeah
and by new york they mean chelsea they
mean about eight square blocks there you
go that's truffle targeted it's just the
east side right there yeah
so uh can we just if law enforcement
didn't already have enough of a tough
job in new york
thugs in the street and i think this
happened yesterday if i'm not mistaken
making it
harder of course here you go
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
wouldn't you just assume they were
filming death wish 5 if you walked by
this yeah yeah
i do sound like plastic a guy squaring
off with a cop
that's like a bear before hibernation
where they just don't care anymore right
there is no respect for the general sort
of checks and balances with a police
officer it means a mob it doesn't hit
cops no
well not in that way no
even then you put a whack out on a cop
it's a big deal i saw donny brasco just
think about that
it's not that you see these people
squaring up and hitting police officers
what do you mean these people i mean the
people in that clip
what did you mean now it's that there is
no fear of rep retribution or
accountability because of the catch and
release programs because of the kind of
defunding that we've seen across the
country they've been emboldened we've
seen a crime wave in new york new york
it was like disneyland for a while and
now we're back to the new york of old
where jason voorhees is going to show up
i think
i think we're past it actually at this
point yeah i don't know if it's ever
been this bad well they're also you
think it's worse than the 70s honestly
kinda i mean because if you watch the
beginning of taxi driver where he does
this whole speech and he'll juxtapose it
with that and tell me which scenery is
worse yeah well that's at least he had a
sweet sweet hawk yes i don't see the
first part i don't have enough time i
abbreviate it what were we saying well
that's also what happens when you make
the police officers afraid to defend
themselves because they could either be
sued or they could you know god forbid
something really bad could happen i mean
those guys bottles are flying through
the air hitting a cop in the head with a
bottle from 50 feet 30 feet 20 feet
whatever it is
could knock that cop down on the ground
kill him you could do a lot of damage
and so what's the appropriate response
well what we've told police officers is
just stand there and kind of take it
well we don't want police officers to
have guns now they do there but they
don't if the left again you always have
to think what would the left have if
they were completely unfettered no guns
okay then they didn't want tasers we've
covered that extensively they didn't
want cops to have tasers then they don't
want chokeholds right
what are you left with yeah what do you
respond to these people with oh you
didn't have to you didn't have to tase
this guy you didn't have to pull your
gun on this guy he was just throwing
glass bottles at you i don't know if
it's a legal defense but if i were a
police officer i would say correct i
didn't have to but i felt like it but i
did this has been go ahead
well the guy squares off and the cop
actually does the same thing right back
at him that's terrifying it is the cops
shouldn't that i will say this this kind
of pose from a comp can escalate it yes
yeah you know you don't want to do that
first off this exposes you and you're
completely rigid and you're not really
in a good self-defense stance so i i
hope that they train police officers
better you can de-escalate it with your
body language nothing would have worked
at that point when they were throwing
their bottles of mickeys
so um
i think uh you know a nice nice few ass
beatings being administered would be a
feel-good ending unfortunately it didn't
go down that way but hey
if you want to see what the left gets
look to near and detroit but in this
case new york this has been empire state
of crimewatch
[Music]
you know i just realized in that new
york song jay-z effectively doxes robert
de niro yeah
now i'm down in tribeca right next to de
niro he's like come on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's what i meant come on
it's a it's a walk up
[Laughter]
look that's a problem then they know
where i live and don't know where i live
you got a problem yes you do yes you you
do you have a problem look at me you
have a problem
i had a ponytail for a while it wasn't
good no one good
one good
it was me and harrison ford had a
meeting he went with the earrings i went
to ponytail we both made mistakes
everything was worse
not monkey pox mistakes but mistakes
he's probably made some monkey box
mistakes too oh i'm sure he is
meanwhile joe pesci's just hiding out
from the law i'll tell it on i'll tell
it on mug club i have a story about joe
pesci or he wouldn't go to california
because he didn't understand that you
didn't need to be extradited if you just
go to a different state
it involves ben shapiro joe pesci and
the lapd okay now we'll move on to this
demi lovato
i know you're saying that you don't care
you do
no you don't but here's why it does
matter because this does relate to
something that we've seen as a larger
trend with kids wanting to transition
when we were kids right we would follow
a lot of these role models i mean demi
lovato was she nickelodeon or was she
disney
i have no idea one of those pedophile
networks i don't know which one yeah she
was touched by somebody yes exactly not
an angel right i said disney twice her
parents left her unsupervised with a
producer and multiple leather couches in
a trailer
so demi lovato now is saying that she's
a girl again remember she changed her
pronouns so let's let's give you the
breakdown here because we covered this
uh back
then
demi lovato made this huge announcement
regarding her pronouns and it was absurd
then as it is now i want to take this
moment to share something very personal
with you over the past year and a half
i've been doing some healing and
self-reflective work and through this
work i've had the right
ring i identify as non-binary
with that said i'll officially be
changing my pronouns to they them i feel
that this best representation she
identified as lloyd christmas
and allows me to feel most authentic and
true to the person i both know i am and
still am discovering oh true to the
person that she knows she is knows no
she is this is that key word because
that would then
classify that under the category of fact
but facts change
and by that i mean whatever it is that
you want to mean that day because let's
go to now she just announced that she's
changed her identity again and uh it
turns out that she's just uh a dumb
broad i i've actually adopted the
pronouns of she her again
so for me
i'm such a fluid person that i don't
remember more gelatinous
i don't find that i am i'm kind of
[ __ ] i felt like
especially last year my energy was
balanced and my friends
so that when i was faced with the choice
of walking into a bathroom and it said
women and men i didn't feel like there
was a bathroom for me because i didn't
feel necessarily like a woman i didn't
feel like a man
um i just felt like a human
and that's what they them is is about
for me it's just about like feeling
human at your core what
recently i've been feeling more feminine
your core well speaking of that it's
time for you to work at sweetheart also
i think it's important to note that uh
you can't base your entire biology and
they want to say gender identity but
let's go back to let's go back to the
old school biology based on where you
want to take a dump
yeah
she said i didn't realize there wasn't a
bathroom for me
so where you wanted to make a deposit is
what determines
a womanhood it's it's just it's just so
absolutely patronizing by the way in
other news elliott page has uh changed
his her
z's preferred pronouns now to uh both
douche and bag so that is one yeah it's
just it's a it's an epidemic of them
changing which one's the plural i'm not
sure doesn't matter i'm not sure so demi
lovato has over 130 million um instagram
followers right 130 million
impressionable young minds that are
paying attention to what you're saying
and you came out last year and said that
this was super important i know exactly
what i am right now now you come out and
say actually i feel like my energy is
balanced i feel like i don't i don't
have a restroom that's the word i would
use for her balance yeah exactly
balanced
well adjusted but here's the thing on
her instagram page right now she still
has they them she and she added she her
she's a really she's a busy girl what
she is doing now and i can say she but
you could also say they is including
both sets of pronouns so now she has all
of them now
and i'm not i swear to you i'm not
pushing anything on her saying that
she's got history of mental illness she
does she's been very open about that but
given that that is something that she's
talked about before don't you think that
you you kind of walk with a little bit
more caution into subjects like this
before you push this out to your 100
million plus followers no and it's not
that she does that that's not the
problem the problem is that the media
treated it as absolutely legitimate when
it happened as opposed to asking the
question that you are asking which is a
perfectly legitimate and a very
important question and this is what it
what it brings us to you know give an
example when i was a kid
i was a little i was a little that was a
little [ __ ] okay because of captain
planets you used to do those psas you
said don't wear fur yeah and so my mom
had this really nice expensive parka
that she got off of this show when she
was a wardrobe stylist and it had a fur
on the hood and i was like i can't wear
it mom because it says don't wear fur on
captain planet and i was like but this
is a nice is going to keep you warm when
it's negative 30 we were in montreal
yeah and i said no captain planet she
and she got really mad she's like okay
okay i'll pick off the she did a really
crappy job so it looked like a pubic
hair beard so i still had remnants of
the fur around my parka now take that
stupid influence where kids change their
minds all the time
and apply gender theory which is very
new modern gender theory to the mix and
of course you can influence young
children and even more so when they
don't just see someone who's on
nickelodeon someone who's on disney but
they see everyone in legitimate media
saying oh yeah this is are they them
this is a person who's gender fluid this
matters because we've talked about this
more and more children are claiming that
they're trans but guess what 87 of kids
grow out of it completely they
completely grow out of it if you don't
do anything keep in mind people like
let's not say ariana
grande it's demi lovato how they all
sort of bleed together
um
they will grow out of it if you don't
intervene these same people were
advocating for intervention by the way
there are people who actually the child
protective services should be able to
take your kids away if you do not
intervene if you do nothing eighty-seven
percent of children grow out of it if
you put them on puberty blockers
zero percent yeah grow out of it zero
percent that is a very important
statistic considering that forty two
percent of trans nine non-binary
individuals attempt suicide by the way
both pre and post transition so when you
have these people going out there and
acting as though this is established
science and you have social media
platforms removing people even episodes
of this program jordan peterson removed
from twitter yeah for not using the
pronouns that elliott page will likely
change within the next 20 years anyway
it gives it legitimacy to kids because
it makes it seem as though adults have
decided on this and here's something we
do know the fda just announced that
puberty blockers uh are dangerous hmm
for kids we had no idea things like
brain swelling and vision loss that's a
nice way of saying tumor yeah how do you
fix brain swelling drill into the side
of that right drill just make sure you
die in the right bathroom yep well that
is important somebody said you have to
go to the bathroom honestly and i hate
to go back to it and you have to decide
which one to go into you don't have to
go to the bathroom no you're not bad
i've gone into the ladies room no i'm
gonna yeah i could be a felon because if
there's a mailbox nearby if everything's
lost i've used buckets yeah we've all
been in situations where it's like i
have no choice yeah i don't care what i
feel like in certain moments i'm using
something that has a toilet too you
could have warned me though because then
i went hitting mailboxes with my bat
afterwards
it's that kind of a fail
and i had the rear window open yeah
you make a great point like these are
impressionable people projectile
diarrhea let's
[Laughter]
yeah exactly the children part is the
important part there's a lot of people
that made decisions and and i understand
this like there can be back and forth
with people on this discussion right i'm
fine i don't really care what demi
lovato chooses to do i care about what
happens to the people who follow her and
go oh that's fantastic because all of
the people around like you said said oh
this is to be applauded this is 100
normal right she can go and basically
transition
verbally right she doesn't have to do
anything we can't have a back and forth
discussion but they can have a back and
forth switch of genders they can but how
many kids that follow demi lovato how
many people that are fans of demi
lovato's music and well basically
worship at the altar of demi lovato went
out and said well i'm trans now mom and
dad we need to talk about puberty
blockers or maybe i had a surgery or
think about how many people can't
go and do what she just did she just
basically said ah you know i think i'm
going to go this way now they're like
well crap i'm stuck on the ride already
yeah it was just a place she wants to be
the new sharer madonna lady gaga and
having no idea at all well the problem
is it's if you're supposed to embrace
yourself they do everything that opposes
that right it's like pretending you're
everything else but you were born with
how is that a good thing yeah i love how
we tell women it's like you don't need
to look a certain way because society
tells you i think that i'm a woman okay
put on this makeup put on this push-up
bra get some fake tits you know it's
like well a second so when a guy decides
that he wants to look like a barbie doll
to perpetuate the stereotype of a girl
it's beautiful and brave but we tell
girls that they should go out you know
in flood pants and no makeup which by
the way is also a problem keep in mind
the uk children's gender identity clinic
okay it's now closing
this is this is the i guess you would
say the largest or certainly uh at the
forefront of this uh and they've been
advocating and spearheading this it's
closing after doctors did raise concerns
that uh children were being referred to
this gender transitioning pathway way
too quickly the number went from like
100 something a few years ago to 5 000.
combine that with brain swelling combine
that with vision loss look we all know
we all know that this is bad for you
this is the issue the left says follow
the science waiting room from
beetlejuice yes
pancake robin williams going by on the
clothesline
[Laughter]
and i should note the uk is opening new
clinics and stuff so they're gonna
offset it it's like you know it's like
[ __ ] and offsets that's what they're
doing yeah so the issue here is is
really that um
we know it's bad for you they say trust
the science well okay
why are you eating organic food
why are you using bpa free plastic why
are you careful about what you put in
the microwave because it might upset
your endocrine system that's the primary
reason these are what we call
xenoestrogens right people talk about
you don't want these they put hormones
in the milk
why why would that be bad for you if the
science is out
when you inject estrogen directly into a
little boy's ass cheek or you give a
little girl testosterone so she grows a
mustache at 12 years old why would we
care about hormones in horizon milk
there's no consistency and we say well
the science is out the science really
isn't out for full-grown women who get
breast cancer for full-grown women who
are going through problems with
metastasis what do they do right away
they put them on some sort of estrogen
blocker some aromatase inhibitor to sort
of stop that negative feedback loop
because we know that it's pro cancer we
know that it can be uh
it can create an environment foster
environment where cancer grows more
rapidly and even worse in young men but
this is but we don't know the only the
only reason this is the sleight of hand
okay
the only reason they can get away with
saying that is because this is new and
it's experimental and we don't have the
long-term studies on children taking
these drugs we do know what happens to
adults who alter their hormones beyond
biologically normal levels it's not good
we've known it for a long time there are
plenty of long-term studies and more
clinical data than you can read in a
lifetime they're just saying we don't
have it on children i'm sure the outcome
will be much better by the way if we're
removed here on youtube you can watch us
live monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern on rumble you can subscribe to
the podcast the audio podcast on spotify
apple android of course mug club
we have an additional full hour of show
today and it's a parody week the last
week of august first week of september
and that'll be released as an album on
spotify all of our parodies i can't wait
all right anyone have anything else
there lovato okay no i'm i'm as confused
as ever yes so are 130 some odd million
people dave yeah
well i'm just glad that she knows who he
is yes
she's being true to herself she knows
who they is they is i'm sorry
so now let's go to uh kansas and this is
something that's trending everywhere it
is confusing it needn't be so confusing
let me just set the stage marley was
dead to begin with okay
abortion is still the same it's
basically as a roby wade never happened
in kansas and this is the same in a lot
of states just to be really clear about
it and i want you to you know comment
below what it is that you've read on
this and if you found yourself a little
bit confused the way they framed this
bill was very confusing yeah okay and
where do you line up if you are
pro you know the change of roe v wade or
if you're pro abortion
what you think about this what you think
about the vote on the individual state
level because i'm not going to start a
march or a protest kansas can do what
they want to do i agree it's a crappy
state anyway so
august 2nd kansas became the first date
to vote tornadoes yeah that's about it
bring you to weird places made a movie
about you and it was a witch getting
killed by a tornado dropping a house
well kansas city isn't even there i mean
they have one there it's the lesser
kansas yeah that's true cut in half it
doesn't make any sense are you guys
doing it's like east st louis is not
really st louis yeah that's in illinois
i got stranded there one time and a
crappy old taurus yeah east st louis
city windshield wipers well you st louis
is the city no no i told you about the
crappy taurus
all right so uh this happened august 2nd
kansas became the first state to vote
directly on the right to
abortion in the post row world hold on a
second no apocalypse yet we'll keep you
posted yeah um before we go to this clip
on kansas kansasians kansans kansans uh
discussing their opinions on this bill
uh i've never seen i don't understand
why lesbians are so concerned with
abortion
if they say straight men heterosexual
men are certainly affected by abortion
more than lesbians
so as i play this clip let's also play a
little game called spot the lesbian
let's roll it it was kind of
intimidating i'm not going to lie but
i'm glad i got to partake in this
choosing yes or no for an abortion
related issue value them both in kansas
well actually was my first time voting
too so i felt like it made a big impact
and i just wanted to be able to help
people that maybe are younger and don't
really understand what's going on for
when they grow up i don't think i should
have to be coming up here and voting on
that that should be my right but others
voted yes i wanted to do what
god would help us to do and i didn't
want to be influenced by the course of
this world a few voters based their last
lady with her husband black lady that
surprised the reporter i don't believe
that abortion should be in the hands of
a person a person should life is created
by god he is the only one that has the
right to
to bring life or take take life i voted
no because if god gives us the right to
choose between good and evil and right
and wrong i think that we should have
the ability for that same choice okay
let me just address that really quickly
that last part
this is where the abortion arguments
fall apart you know we do these change
my minds on a lot of topics everything
from build the wall donald trump is not
a fascist time per second the easiest
one honestly is abortion
because it falls apart now regardless of
where someone lines up there is a very
difficult path to an argument for people
like that to make that last lady seem
like a nice lady in the mass the black
lady uh she said uh i it's only it's
only for god to judge
well sure
we understand what you mean ultimate
judgment but hold on a second
is it are you saying that it's taking a
life if so we go back to question one do
we have laws for murder do you believe
that only god can judge for
grand theft auto for arson
for murder no it doesn't hold water you
do have to answer whether you believe
the act is the termination of a life or
not and they always avoid it yeah in
their justification so now the votes are
in i think we have a clip
kansas voters the first to vote on an
abortion related ballot vote on your
dennis haircut turn roe v wade and
frankly that ruling proved to be
energized sitting on that slingshot the
state constitutional right to an
abortion to be undone by the amendment
it was a state court supreme court
ruling that put that in place
the
amendment itself would not ban abortion
but it would have set the stage for
legislative oversight
all right to be clear kansas is an
overwhelmingly red state so it surprised
a lot of people uh abortion is still
legal in kansas just you know up until
22 weeks that's five and a half months
right
all right is this
really gonna act as though this is this
is a handmaid's tale
[Applause]
for stephen king yes exactly that's
pretty much right and basically he just
at the very end of his quote he said
this wouldn't have made it illegal it
would have just put the power to do that
in the hands of the state legislature
right not necessarily in the hands of
the supreme court that's all this was
and it was an incredibly confusing vote
if you read the ballot you would have
had to take some time to make sure
because the way that they worded it
made you wonder like i don't know what
is what now at the bottom they said if
you vote yes this is what it means if
you vote no but i i understand human
nature and they're not going to read
it's like what they do with prop 8 in
california they use double negatives and
then they go yes or no and you're like i
don't understand why you're saying they
quoted the constitution in there and i'm
like why did you add that i get that
it's relevant put it down in a quote
below all of this so that they can see
it separately it's like did anybody like
did anybody oh you were expecting it to
not be nonsensical
gerald should you have the right to kill
babies yes or no basically the idea was
would they have the right to have
restrictions like texas that would come
into play before the uh uh that wouldn't
have been allowed before the overturning
i'm getting confused just even saying it
before roe v wade you couldn't put in
limitations only in the first trimester
after roe v wade you can for example a
heartbeat bill in kansas they basically
the state legislature cannot put any
restrictions on it so it's still
abortion kansas up until 22 weeks that's
five and a half months for reference
kansas a red state uh it became a
destination state for abortion tourism
in 2020 yeah it's up nine percent by the
way uh after their supreme court
decision and by the way
this abortion tourism was almost
entirely from people they were traveling
from texas and oklahoma oh my gosh to
kansas well one of the one of the quotes
that i read actually said that about
fifty percent of abortions in kansas
were from people out of state yeah
that's insane that is well so the left's
next caused azure remember we went from
abortion safe legal and rare yeah right
was abortion safely it first started
with abortion rape and incest okay then
they said safe legal and rare then it
became shout your abortion now it's wait
hold on a second you have to pay as a
taxpayer uh to send people across state
lines to get abortion that's what they
want you to have to subsidize there's
never going to be an end to it just look
at what happens with what happens with
the gender bender you give them an inch
they're never going to stop it's why you
don't apologize whether you agree with
some of their points or not you just
have to say ah no because sooner or
later you're going wait a second i'm
paying for people to travel to panama to
get an abortion at nine months how the
hell did that happen
abortion bnb the new app yes
bermuda no baby yes so let's go through
a couple of things here just that will
confuse you here's a claim that uh they
are making uh the democrat uh
governor kansas laura kelly she said
this would throw the state back into the
dark ages talking about you know the
idea if the bill won't have gone through
good god legislators in topeka with no
medical training have no right to make a
woman's medical decision it must go to
the angry lesbians
who have no medical training let's go
take a poll of those with mullets at
bass pro
if you use a turkey baster you've made
the choice to have a kid right yeah yes
no i'm not just being honest no if you
can't
why would you get pregnant then be like
i want an abortion for fun i just like
to have it i like to have it for peace
of mind dave well by the way sorry i'm
sorry it must be nice to be cis male 1 i
don't grant the premise it's not though
it's not anymore this is not a medical
decision no this is not a purely medical
decision this isn't you deciding to have
maybe some uh additional pounds removed
or maybe have a facelift or
butt implants for those of us not
blessed like
private this is you deciding to end a
life that is not a private medical
decision
is it also a private medical decision to
get vaccinated or not yeah do you want
to hold the same standard we've brought
that up before i don't think you do by
the way all the references are available
at loudoscridor.com so you can read uh
the amendment itself and like i said up
to 22 weeks but something else that's
funny you know what appears there
the words pregnant people i know i saw
that that's how you know [ __ ] wrote
this
[Laughter]
women and pregnant people must undergo a
24-hour waiting period
the guy who writes calvin klein ads
right
pregnant person you a pregnant man
so yes
this doesn't exactly sound like the dark
ages laura um let me ask you two here's
a question that i have um how much money
was spent you know to preserve the right
to
kill babies here uh 5.8 million dollars
in television radio digital ads they
were spent by the kansans for
constitutional freedom to preserve their
right uh planned parenthood 850 000 look
here's something i want to talk about
really quickly
um a song with someone
about this the other day
men and women have different problems in
society okay i acknowledge that and i
think at one point would be okay to
acknowledge that because men and women
are different now i've talked about this
in the past when you're a kid people who
are smarter than girls girls was more
than boys okay
here's the truth
there are probably more women who are on
average slightly smarter than men if you
look at the iq there's the way the bell
curve works however men occupy because
we are extreme creatures we're extremist
beasts by nature they occupy both ends
of the bell curve so even if there are
more smart women let's say on average
than men at a certain point there are
only male geniuses statistically at a
certain point though on the flip side
there are only male repeat violent
offenders okay that's the problem that
we usually have with males in society
the problems that we have with women the
problem that most women are dealing with
and i think this is why conservative
women have such a disconnect because we
have three four women who are working
out here now i know they wouldn't relate
to this
feminism appealed to the idea with women
that you should never have to experience
discomfort
that's how you end up with abortion up
to five and a half weeks or you're
against my choice no hold on a second
i'm pro-choice abstinence contraception
motherhood adoption what do they say
well i hope you never have to put up a
baby for adoption that's a really tough
choice i'm not saying that it's a
comfortable choice but you did make a
choice to have sex assuming it's not
rape or incest which in nearly every
case it's not
now you have a choice to give up the
baby for adoption as opposed to
determining that life the only reason
that you think that's wrong is because
there's this there's this assumption
that you are entitled to not be
uncomfortable in any capacity same thing
with women getting the right to vote
well women got the right to vote but you
didn't have to be drafted
why well you shouldn't have to
experience any discomfort you had sex
you had a one-night stand you weren't
responsible enough to use a plan b pill
you weren't responsible enough to use
contraception you should be able to have
an abortion right because you couldn't
shouldn't have to experience the
discomfort
of a baby and so what you see is women
have been promised they have been
catered to they've been pandered to and
it's insulting women you let me know
comment below if you find it insulting
that you shouldn't possibly have to deal
with discomfort we see this in
relationships 80
the lowest number you'll find is 76 the
number i believe from i don't know if it
was uh
i don't know if it was nih i don't know
if it was the cdc uh number of divorces
in this country now 80 are filed by
women okay
domestic abuse has gone down cheating
has gone down over 70 percent of women
listed as their primary reason for
divorce a lack of commitment on the
man's part we have no no fault divorce
laws which means it's always the primary
earners
fault and usually that's the mail so you
shouldn't have to experience slight
discomfort if you go and read on
feminist blogs type in right now run a
google run a bing
if you're on a public library that old
bent back paper clip who pops up to tell
you how to spell words correctly ask
jeeves yes you can ask jeeves um
run a search feminist blogs women filing
for divorce and they will consider this
a win it's women today
are
far less likely to remain in unhappy
relationships well we do you think that
men are going through a private hell
women sometimes in marriage sometimes
you make our life difficult but
statistically men don't walk nearly as
much as women because we have never been
promised the right
to not experiencing discomfort that has
never been a right a promise even a
notion afforded to men and so women file
80 of divorces and they walk because
they don't like the relationship and i
shouldn't be uncomfortable in this
relationship it's the same issue that
we're dealing with with abortion and on
the flip side let's look you know let's
look at black americans this is a really
good kind of petri dish okay
what do you have if you listen to black
americans they say what are the primary
problems with young men
gang violence drugs not all black
americans it is a disproportionate
problem though in specifically
impoverished black neighborhoods okay
women
baby mamas who don't work
who are on the welfare dole so in one
example it's you shouldn't have to be
uncomfortable so live off of the
government teat for the rest of your
life in the other it's men you are
promised nothing so do whatever it takes
start selling drugs join a gang because
it's sink or swim on your own this is
the primary divide that we see between
men and women men have never been
promised the idea
that you will never experience
discomfort that is ev if you look at any
feminine issue anyone take a pic pick
one abortion
take a a
free tampons you shouldn't have to go
through this discomfort of purchasing
your own tampons
you shouldn't have to go through this
company whatever it is
that's a problem
and it's been used to buy your votes and
it's harmed women and you know what you
can scream until you're blue in the face
and say yeah well we need to we need to
uh uh we need to reconcile what's
happened in the past and we need to make
sure that uh there's justice today for
women in the past you didn't have as
many rights but okay you know what just
don't expect to get married because 40
something percent of young men don't
want to get married because they see it
as an inequitable distribution
that's it
you've got a choice to make
women are less happy than ever
they do less work around the house less
fewer household chores than ever because
it's been more automated they're making
more money than ever and they are less
happy than ever statistically because
they will never catch that dragon they
are chasing of a life completely devoid
of discomfort that's the end of my sorry
i wish my roomba loved me
your roommate does love you
what
what is that you hear that
what sorry i think it's coming from the
building just some delicious build bars
plus i like to eat when i'm bored bored
and watching this show you're lucky you
don't have a belly like dave
i like built bars too i ate them after i
work out yeah yeah you do
does that work out the walk you do to or
from your car
he goes up a couple stairs too
oh yeah okay and you guys are just the
epitome just throw you down them
[Laughter]
your guy's just in peak physical shape
right is that you're the epitome of
health huh
is that well we're old yeah what's your
excuse
[Laughter]
and stephen you're not quite benching as
much as you used to huh oh i i had chest
surgery so i don't really think that's
yeah
that was the chest surgery
is that because you'd like to dress up
like a woman so much on this show that
you decided to just get implants
probably just felt right
dave's looked botched
i wish this was a welfare ad i seriously
do yeah i really wish this was a ball
threat yeah
all right okay i draw the line at death
threats
gerald
got some build bars here enjoy them
after a workout as a meal replacement or
while verbally abusing your friends yeah
well look you can go to built.com use a
promo code crowder15 get 15 off i need
them to actually send me some more yeah
these are the built for the puffs
they're like marshmallow puffs they're
actually pretty damn good did you get
those
i don't know well they're sitting around
i found them the other day though
they're very tasty yeah they are tasty
they taste
what's the candy bar that has the
marshmallow in it
s'mores no it's the yellow one i didn't
say what you make by the campfire
you can't commercially sell
can't fire no they have like uh dead
little debbie s'mores or something yeah
yeah yeah but i know one should they
they're like the reese's cup but they're
marshmallow
by the way oh i don't know if you know
what there is a wrong way to eat reese's
no there's nothing anally oh geez no
that's actually not the wrong way oh
i'll fill you in later what i guessed oh
it wasn't a bad guess but it was a wrong
guess okay oh i'm glad that's the right
way then so now we have this and you
know what this is something that's near
uh to you because you had a dad who was
a veteran yes right and didn't your if
i'm not mistaken your dad went uh
experience wasn't he around agent orange
uh it was because of agent orange yeah
died of a cell sarcoma right brain
cancer which the uh government did
nothing we've been fighting for years
about it um yeah yeah the va i know that
you ran into problems with it still do
yeah yeah and it's we've essentially
been roadblocked and i think uh yeah we
can definitely get into this but i yeah
this is definitely something that's very
near and dear to my heart i think it's
important because this is the case with
a lot of people if you have a relative
who's a veteran and so this is
unfortunately
what we see and it's a very typical ploy
you really don't see it as much from the
right and the reason for that is because
it's tough for the right to justify a
bunch of pork barrel spending right
they'll just get voted out by their
constituents but the poison pill and a
bill is something that the left does
incredibly well did you know about this
this is my question to you did you know
about the 390 something billion dollars
in the burn pit bill you know for
veterans that had nothing to do with
veterans and that's the problem it's
always the problem is they stuff
everything into a bill that has nothing
to do with the bill that is actually
going to help the people it's supposed
to happen that's exactly right so uh on
tuesday the senate did pass the what was
controversial and it didn't change at
all the pact this is we'll just call it
the burn pit bill um which expands
health care access to the veterans
who've been exposed to and by the way
we all would support that because the
government screwed up and harmed our
veterans that is a legitimate purview of
government to fix that yeah right to
right that wrong especially as it
relates to people who've put their lives
on the line here's a clip to fill you in
this is a very good day
a long awaited day a day that should
have happened long ago
for decades many of our nation's
veterans have endured a shameful reality
they went abroad to serve our country
bravely
got sick from toxic exposure in the line
of duty but came home and learned they
didn't qualify for the benefits they
needed to treat their illnesses it is
truthful
it is infuriating
today we tell our veterans suffering
from cancers lung diseases other
ailments from burn pits the wait is over
for the benefits you deserve okay so
just so you know people who voted nay
notable rand paul mike lee i'll explain
to you why uh the bill failed in the
senate just last week yeah it's
basically the same bill now last week
and this is the reason the bill went
through and republicans caved wrongfully
so
jon stewart went on his uh his press
tour and was ripping people like pat
toomey and other republicans for not
voting for the bill under what under the
guise that you must not care about
veterans
scientists
ain't this
america's heroes
just point to a public school teacher
fought in our wars sure which is
outside sweating their asses off
with oxygen
battling
all kinds of ailments while these
sit in the air conditioning
walled off from any of it i'm used to
the lies
i'm used to the hypocrisy
senator pat toomey won't take a meeting
with the veterans group maybe just
because he called him a coward and a
[ __ ] sends out as chief of staff
i'm used to the cowardice i've been here
a long time
senate's where accountability goes to
die these people don't care they're
never losing their jobs support
terminology that's trying to bring their
health care pat toomey didn't lose his
job he's walking away god knows what
kind of pot of gold he's stepping into
no it's ironic that he uses the term pot
of gold so look this is what i want to
do a mental exercise with you right now
because a lot of people have actually
they'll reach out they'll go through our
our email um contacts on the website
like tips at loudestcar.com or something
like that and they'll say hey
i just i know that there's something
going on with this burn pit bill the
packed act but i don't exactly know what
it is because i do think that veterans
should be taken care of
why are republicans voting against this
okay
here are the questions that you should
ask if something feels off let's start
with figuring out why it feels off does
this pass the sniff test
basic logical questions okay
are republicans typically the party
that don't support veterans
is it typically the democratic party who
want to actually reform the va actually
increase efficiencies actually want to
create an effective military not a
social justice petri dish is are the
democrats the party that have been
pro-military pro-veterans okay let's ask
that does this seem in line with whether
you like them or not with what
republicans would do not helping
veterans let's ask a follow-up question
why would they be willing to commit
political suicide for something that
seems like a bill that everyone would be
on board with
if you ask those questions it's pretty
easy to get to the answer okay uh the
bill
400 billion dollars but billion i i had
to say it three times fast before the
show because in my mind i want to say
million but that's a rounding error 400
billion dollars made it into this bill
was discretionary spending and it was
made mandatory that by the way has
nothing to do nothing nothing whatsoever
it can be spent however they want
in this bill here's pat toomey
explaining it before he was just uh you
know insulted by jon stewart what do you
say
to those who find it impossible to
believe that of all the multi-trillions
of dollars in our federal budget this is
where you and republicans decided to
take a stand
geez
here's what you need to keep in mind
jake first of all
this is the oldest trick in washington
people take a sympathetic group of
americans and it could be children with
an illness it could be victims of crime
it could be veterans who've been exposed
to toxic chemicals
craft a bill to address their problems
and then sneak in something completely
unrelated that they know could never
pass on its own and dare republicans to
do anything about it because they know
they'll unleash their allies in the
media and maybe a pseudo celebrity to
make up false accusations to try to get
us to just swallow what shouldn't be
there that's what's happening here jake
yeah you wrote about it on his website
and we have the references available at
loudercredit.com you can go and read the
bill right you can go and read the act i
have a question jake tapper why didn't
you ask maybe a more probing question to
get to the heart of the matter instead
of trying to paint republicans as
anti-va why didn't you say hey in the
senate you guys passed this bill earlier
this year when it went to the house it
was actually changed a little bit and
came back to you guys and that's when
you voted no on it what change that made
you vote no that would have been a real
journalist 400 billion things changed
yeah well
what's 400 billion between friends
stephen right yeah
having
been part of fighting this when my dad
died as a teenager uh you look at
i've done this to the clinton
administration the bush administration
the obama administration the closest we
can to getting paid was the trump
administration yeah and now we're in
this so they they recently just started
paying out mustard gas because there's
so few people left in connection to
where they can cough out a couple
dollars for that right this is what has
always gone on they always give so very
little to the veterans and slap all this
money on the back end and i've watched
this happen time and time again
for 20 years right over 20 years well
and the thing is it's actually it's it's
more pernicious than that because the
democrats know it
they beca they can only do this because
they don't care about the veterans
because it's not it's not a voting base
for them that's why they need to change
the military that's why they need to
have they and them pronouns and stretchy
maternity suits for
pregnant seven seven-month pregnant
feminists in the air force they don't
care about the military it's not a
voting block and so they're willing to
make the sacrifice meaning sacrifice the
health of our veterans as long as it
makes republicans look bad they want to
make republicans look better so they
don't care about the veterans meanwhile
they know that they don't care about the
veterans because they're putting in 400
billion dollars and by the way this is
not the only time this has been done all
references again available at
loudercutter.com let me just give you a
few off the top of my head more recently
in july 2022 democrats right in the
house committee they voted to insert
more funding for the cdc and nih remove
the hyde amendment and the budget bill
in march 2022
biden's 1.5 trillion dollar spending
bill included billions of dollars in
pork barrel spending of course in
democrat districts may 2019 house
democrats added a and this is referred
to as a poison pill because they
deliberately want to poison it so they
can then score political points uh
bailouts for obamacare uh
to bipartisan uh health care legislation
right they added this last minute and
then go what you don't support health
care for people what you don't support
the veteran no no that's not what it is
it's like you're giving me minestrone
soup only there's
[ __ ] in it
i don't have a problem with the
minestrone soup per se
it's
the [ __ ] in the soup oh you mean the
slumber party they had right yeah it was
ridiculous yeah and i understand john
stewart's rage i honestly don't and i
think he comes from a good place
especially with even
911 and people that have dealt with it
yeah i just think that he has to
understand that every every move forward
just because there's something good in
it doesn't mean it's actually going to
bring in the result that you want
exactly and you can't just blame one
party for it this is a problem in all of
politics
this is a fault of right and left a lot
but the people you see doing it the most
are the democrats because this has been
the most they're the most difficult
group to get veterans paid out and i've
experienced this firsthand and i have a
mountain of evidence that can show that
yeah no you're absolutely right and by
the way hey uh
what about the 400 billion just going to
the actual veterans why would you
sandwich that into a bill 100
how about right there is your problem
yeah you can fix the problem right there
there's your money and john stewart
tries to so it's only republican do we
do we actually think john stuart doesn't
know uh he knows of course he knows he
doesn't know what he's doing he should
be going after somebody like chuck
schumer who went down to the floor there
and just had a moment where he's like
finally
chuck you've been there a long time yeah
why just now i read the bill i spent a
lot of time this morning going through
line by line you're fixing problems back
to the vietnam war and before before
what were you doing with all the other
time joe biden former vice president you
were there as well those small children
aren't going to princess leia chained
themselves up themselves chuck schumer
is at every opportunity yeah and now
he's coming out and saying oh finally
we're able to do this well the only
people standing in the way of you doing
this was you yeah so you finally got out
of the way and your [ __ ] lateral
move sorry pardon my legs is not a move
forward no that's not what they have to
realize that's the same game they play
over and over again to get more of
taxpayer funding to do whatever they
want with why didn't you just decades
ago have your freaky little lemony
snicket's hand write this up in a way
that was straightforward and would
actually help the veterans so why did
you drag soldiers over into a conflict
that didn't involve us right
yeah i mean i
there's so and then afterwards they say
oh the iraq war took home a second and
you supported it until you were against
it right this is the issue that all of
them have and i think that there's a
perfectly legitimate position to hold if
you were against the war or for the war
my issue is when you just change it
based on where the political winds are
blowing and you use veterans as a pawn
or you use whoever it is single moms as
a pawn take your pick
you use our children as pawns with covid
we're not pawns to be used by
politicians this is the problem the
fundamental problem of a government that
sees you as subservient to them versus
serving them
by the way when you send when we commit
to send our troops overseas the very
first dollar in your spending bills goes
to them correct your very first dollar i
don't care if you support the war or not
the very first dollar when they come
home goes to supporting them that has
been the republican mantra there is no
way republicans are standing in the way
of this right there's no way no they
don't think about this for a second
donald trump the only trump uh the only
president in modern american history to
not start a new war and he's the guy who
did most for veteran reform for va
reform it was the first time i got
through i was able to talk to somebody i
almost had a check written out and it's
not even about the money i'll rip the
thing up i've finally gotten them to at
least admit well don't rip it up you can
at least
cash
we'll do one of those happy gilmore
checks and you can raise that one but
it's just like take accountability and
they have that's the crazy part they
take accountability but then the second
that it switched to biden it comes back
to well your mom didn't file the
paperwork just right well she was
mentally ill because her husband died
yeah and she took her life yeah and it's
like well what the paperwork wasn't it's
like what what is wrong with you people
the only way she should have to file it
is roll it up and have chuck schumer
bend over oh absolutely that would be
the best way to submit it and then rub
his face in it
rub his face and triple ear marks
hey hey common ground common ground here
uh question
can we all agree that there shouldn't be
ear marks in a bill
yeah we do away with that 100 just
completely i remember when i first heard
about earmarks do you remember where you
were when you first i remember exactly
where i was i was in an office in el
segundo
uh i was 19 years old when someone
actually explained it to me and they
went through all the technical jargon
they explained it to me in a way that i
couldn't possibly understand as just uh
one of those uh plebes
that's okay okay
so basically
it means they can add
and whatever else to the bill it's like
the film blank check yeah yeah yeah
it is though and he was like well not
really and he explained it again and i
said
so basically it's you can have a bill
that's in relation anything let's say
veterans uh let's say it's a bill in
relation to i don't know border security
security for a guy in his russian [ __ ]
malibu yeah or his chinese spy horse
eric swalwell i don't want to say i'm
looking at you
but come on
uh
i asked again so it's just and 100
million or in this case i remember
saying 100 million more for this
today that's a joke we're talking about
400 billion before you fact-check me i
think it's like 396 billion just to be
clear i round it up a little bit so sue
me let's all do away with earmarks
everyone should be able to agree on that
here's a question that i think is
fundamental look at that has flipped a
stupid pen here's a question uh why did
this pac deck the burn pit bill is how
it's kind of been referred to why did it
pass yesterday if it couldn't pass last
week
there were three proposed amendments
from republican senators they were all
rejected by the way these amendments of
course
largely revolved around
a second there's like 400 billion there
yeah what do you have a problem with
that we don't have we have 400 billion
other problems just to be clear yeah
we're worried about distribution not the
not the amount right where is it going
yeah by the way do you really need to
wear a gucci necklace here on the floor
uh schumer it's almost like rubbing it
in
honor of the veteran's
okay so the bill is exactly the same and
senator ted cruz who's been on the show
as a friend of the show stated uh his
support for the pe for the pact on
veterans but he added
i'm disappointed that we couldn't come
together to fix the democrat created
budget gimmick that will allow congress
to subsequently spend another 400
billion on pork and on top of and
completely unrelated to the laudable
funding in this bill for veterans harmed
by burn pits now it's up to republicans
to clean up this mess by lowering the
discretionary cap so that we protect
every penny of veterans funding but
prevent unrelated pork when republicans
retake the majority gerald i mean in
other words basically ted cruz came out
and said this is a really bad deal
there's money going to other places that
we can't control but hey make sure you
vote for us in the upcoming elections
and we'll fix it ted we've been doing
that for a long long
long time do you think anything's
actually going to happen on this post
election nobody's going to come back and
actually put caps on this stuff that's
not going to happen there's money going
out the door and everybody wants a piece
of it including you and the other
republicans who actually held the line
last week and had principles last week
on this until the media started to run
with the fact that you guys didn't
support the va and y'all didn't have
your game ready to come out and say
actually we do and here's a laundry list
of reasons why i can say i'll tell you
exactly why it caved it's b they cave
because they understand a certain
portion of their constituency not all
but there are a lot of veterans out
there just like there are groups of any
other american demographic
who are not particularly educated on
political issues at this point and if
you're not paying attention you are
constantly being pandered to right
veteran-owned company veteran bill and
i'm a vet right they have their palomia
shirt that they drape across their seat
in their truck when they're not there
this is someone who actually knew who
did this that is their their rezone diet
and they should be proud of it and they
are actual heroes unlike tick-tock
nurses that being said republicans don't
want to fall on that sword because
veterans have been used not in the same
way for pork barrel spending but by
i would say some private companies a lot
of businesses a lot of corporations on
the right who say veteran-owned we're
proud veteran-owned we support our
veterans and two percent of their
profits go to veterans and so they're
afraid of these people getting mad at
them and it's a lot easier to just say
yeah yeah yeah we support all the
veterans rather than educating people
saying look look look the reason we have
a problem is because of 400 billion
dollars it's ironically
the only kind of pork that schumer
doesn't have a problem with
you're right though it's how they dip
their toe though into getting a moderate
vote to go their way because they know
that people will sympathize with it to
some degree but the reality is is we do
not have the respect for our soldiers
that we should we're not aware of the
fact that we don't even understand
patriotism like we should we don't have
a grasp of what goes on in the world and
how dangerous and scary that it actually
is the reason why demi lovato can have
18 different pronouns is because there's
not people here that would just kill her
in a heartbeat because of these soldiers
right these are people who have fought
and given their lives to our country and
they deserve some
just some respect and i'm really tired
of seeing how much [ __ ] they have to go
through
to get any kind of money and
compensation for what they've for what
they've dealt with it's pathetic you
know what dave
maybe we could uh we can talk after the
show but you know we have some lines
with the pot and just to be clear i
don't endorse politicians on the show i
have politicians on the show
specifically if i think they're relevant
to an issue
we could make some calls and it might be
good for you to get in front of them i
would love to yeah and by that i mean be
yourself and rip them a new [ __ ] i'd
be happy to yeah a second one for monkey
yes exactly that well yeah well they
already have it yes
different senators you about to say
something no because look look dave
lives this and this is why i've been
deferring to dave and by the way for
people who get mad like why isn't dave
being funny dave has the right to
express an opinion he's passionate about
this for crying out loud thank god the
guy not thank god he has the right to
but i'm surprised he isn't breaking out
in tears you can go and find him
discussing what his dad went through
yeah it's horrible it's hell it's hell
on earth and you know what it's one of
the few legitimate roles of government
to protect us both from external and
internal threats there should be no
other spending or social programs until
the veterans the people who have
actually fought for this country are
taken care of and no libertarians that's
not supporting a welfare state these are
people who went out fought for the
country and especially if you had them
breathing in air from the burn pits if
someone can go on air and allow you to
sue your state whether it's g gordon
liddy because of mesothelioma but if
you're a veteran you're [ __ ] out of luck
william shatner can have you sue
somebody yeah but for a slip and fall
every day of the week i'm jay gardner
lydia shut up
i i wish i wish the republicans would
have come out and said oh okay here you
go guess what here's the real packed act
we're introducing new legislation right
now it has every single other thing in
this bill that supports veterans you
know the 400 billion dollars at sports
veterans that's in the bill you know
it's not in the bill the 400 billion
dollars that doesn't support veterans
that's the only difference vote for that
yeah and they need to say that they need
to they do need to grow up here come out
and just kind of explain that and just
go this is the problem you tag on all
this nonsense and then it's not the bill
you think that it is right
it's it's also why i probably i will
never run for office people say you know
why john stewart has more influence than
ted cruz does for sure think about that
they just caved i do love that rand paul
didn't yeah i do too rand paul
i will i he is he's [ __ ] he's
interested in his manhood too oh maybe
all the other republicans voted for the
bell but not may
and they're like why do you have to do
that rain you're making the rest of us
look better well i didn't come here to
make you look good i came here to
represent my constituents and you're a
dick
i love rand paul that's not an insult i
love that rand paul
he's out of shits to give
good for him
good for him he's one of the few guys
he's very slight but ironically has
large brass pendulous balls all right
we're going to talk about speaking of
pendulous balls ron desantis uh going
after the view yeah there's another
thing please do me a favor you're
watching right now share the show
just hit the share button because the
algorithms if someone searches
louder with crowder veterans bill burn
pits and even etch-a-sketches you know
uses an ipad pencil with dave's face it
still won't show up it'll be a demi
lovato video so uh share the show it
helps with the algorithm hit a like
comment below dave is in dayton ohio
this friday and saturday at the funny
bone i have to go to the bathroom you're
gonna have to hold down the fort here no
because youtube
you gotta piss off i don't wanna say it
i gotta do it do it
c